[Music]
when you watch him play when you're
courtside and you're watching watching
and play
are you are you de mujer you quiet or
you really get into it you ever trash
talk on the side of the court oh I'm bad
well hey I don't sit course I die that
that got killed when I became as vocal
oh you got asked to yeah he's like you
were gonna need you a few rows back what
are you doing what were you doing it was
so bad I'm like dance mom and I'm like
plie plie
you know he's I'm I'm very you know yo
you should be yelling ballet moves hey
star I become like Bobby Knight in like
the Great Santini oh you were just
screaming and you were abusive
yeah like brick you know air ball but
it's like a not yelling us at him are
you where I feel like this is your guy
he was gonna tell him if not jump Brant
that's terrible I also I hackle other
players on opposing teams what's like
the meanest thing you said well there's
a gentleman who shall remain nameless it
was a little a little overweight let's
say and I did yell out his name your
Spanx are showing and he looked you know
cuz I do it like I time it up perfectly
so like for maximum effect right and he
was like he looked and he looked like
hurt and I felt like an awful bully yeah
yeah I think I'm stealing did you ever
go after a ref all the time well like
recently like maybe last week I am there
wasn't there was an older ref perhaps it
was dick Bavetta and I said what do you
think I hadn't blown his whistle the
whole game and I was like
you'll get your viagra if you just make
a call what
these are rough these are really rough
and keep in mind now you've been moved
back by this point so you clearly have a
bullhorn now yeah you're dying here
you're calling people on their cell
phone that's very intense it is a little